[Music]
I got a story for y'all all right this
is what this is what had happened all
right okay A New Mexico family was
rushing to try and save their dog's life
and then they were stopped by the popos
all right and held at gunpoint by the
cops and we have the entire story right
here were they rushing or they speeding
they were speeding and then because of
the kid was
the dog the dog oh or kid or well yeah
or kid some people it's their kid some
people call their kids their dog that's
what I'm saying you good back there
dogup
so here's the story so there was a
neighborhood cat that lured this dog
Stella the lab dooodle into traffic one
day in July stupid cat I was like oh my
God our dog just got hit Tera Alber
recalled she said she was bringing food
inside the house for dinner when she
realized a speeding car in the
neighborhood had hit her dog the alri
family jumped into action terara holding
cell in the passenger seat while her
husband William drove and their teenage
son was in the back seat quote we jumped
in the car and started trying to get to
the ER as fast as we could to try and
save her life he drove down the 550
through Burnal Lilo from the real Rancho
home toward the nearest 24-hour
emergency vet and then they spotted a
police cruiser I imagine if he was going
to pull me over for speeding I'd pull
over he'd say something to me and then
maybe he'd even help us get there you
know I've heard stories like that before
but that didn't happen damn police video
from officer's lapel
footage maybe yeah lapel footage shows
what if you're
speeding officer Jeremy narez is seen
pointing his gun at Alber as he shouts
driver step out of the vehicle the
officer continues shouting commands at
Albert who has his hands in the air face
the [__] away from me the officer shouts
lapel video shows officer Jeremy narez
ordering Albert out of the car at
gunpoint and telling him to to walk
backwards towards traffic step back step
[__] back go to your left officer
narz is shouting as cars passing by on
the busy road my dog's going to die
Albert tries to explain to the officer
who doesn't approach the family's
vehicle realizing what's happening
Albert's wife starts recording on her
cell phone roll the window down Remy
Tera tells her son her cell phone video
shows a vantage point she had as her
husband is directed away from the
family's vehicle I'm thinking this is
unbelievable I can't believe it's like
why didn't someone just check with us
find out the reason our speeding was and
help us she and her son watched him
disbelief as officer directed Alber to
step toward oncoming traffic and get on
his knees step back go to your left
officer Nar shouted [__] faster get
on your knees okay sirens were a potty
mouth
yeah there's a lot of asteris on this
but I'm just saying the full words
because we're hardcore here I need you
okay the sirens were so loud as police
backup arrived and said he was worried
for his family safety lapel video shows
three other officers arrive on the scene
and continue with a felony stop pointing
guns at the family and shouting hands up
Al's wife and 16-year-old son also had
guns pointed in their Direction Al was
handcuffed and he continued trying to
explain the officers my dog's about to
die my dog's about to die I saw my son
was sticking his hands out of the window
too like dude our dog's going to die
Albert recall being fearful for his son
I was scared I was genuinely scared
officer's lapel footage shows a
shortless 16-year-old boy with his hands
in the air pleading with the police our
dog's going to die teen tried to point
to the officers in uh in his mother's
direction to see the their dog was
bleeding from its head and none of them
seemed to even care at the moment at all
I never would have put my son in a
position like that ever I backed the
blue I support the blue like I always
want to show him that you know you
submit to these guys that you're
supposed to be able to trust them he and
his family said they couldn't believe
how they were treated what did we do to
Warrant guns being pointed at our heads
pointing a loaded gun at a man's head
it's a threat you know and I didn't feel
like I earned that threat we're talking
about loaded weapons with One in the
Chamber where if he pulls that trigger
on accident I'm dead my son's dead and
then what then what are they going to
say oh we're sorry there's no sorry for
that police video shows officer shouting
command at Alber as he pleads please my
neighbor hit my dog that's my son and my
wife please sir my dog's about to die
long story short they still said I don't
give a [__] eventually one of the backup
captains goes actually sees that the dog
is bleeding in the car comes back says
let these people go officer narz is
still saying [__] these [__]
they let him go he's still cussing the
whole time he's still cussing the whole
time even as they're powerp huh right
and then from there the dog
doesn't make it of course oh wasted all
that time for what Wast all time it was
a I I didn't I didn't assume it would be
a felony stop as well like the way that
that goes down even even with speeding
well how fast were they going it doesn't
specifically this a [__] perfect [__]
store man yeah cuz if you like you also
don't know what the cop just heard right
if it's over the radio hey sky blue blck
a Buick Regal just pulled a gun at a gas
station like all [__] attention on
that that could be the exact car so nvar
was like oh what the [__] that's that
Buick Regal or whatever so you don't
know 120 yeah you don't know what the
cop is feeling or his context
approaching the car but then at the same
time you feel for the family cuz a
[__] dog dying in the back yeah so
that's why you kind of need like that
extra buffer on both sides but it's it's
it's [__] hard man and especially for
the end of it to be the the captain
being like oh the dog's [__] leeding
you guys can go I think everyone was
like why don't you just look in the car
yeah but before I make any statements
what race was the
family uh White okay good [__]
them it's their
fault yeah no it's [__] up though
super [__] yeah it's also tough cuz
like so um are they it was a white
family MH and then the Mexican
cop oh how the tides have turned
Jeremy navarez I think you can assume
that that is a Hispanic cop uh and then
the Alber yeah they look very white so
that's also super tough because you're
never ever supposed to take the law into
your own hands so if you have an
emergency you call 911 you don't turn
into an ambulance the problem is when
it's your dog I don't know if they would
save save you like if it's your son for
sure ambulance is coming they for
they'll come they'll come pick up your
kid turn the lights on they're running
every single light faster than you can
ever drive so for sure it's going to be
way faster going to the hospital than
you trying to play Hero but when it
comes to your dog though I don't know
like you know I don't think the amb I
don't think there's an ambulance for
dogs so that's why I also kind of like
new business new business let's do it
that's why I kind of empathize for them
I'm like if there is no emergency
services for an animal it kind of makes
you go I guess I have to that's why
everyone should have you know like in
the old undercover day like cop movies
they put that on the top of their thing
everyone we needs like a like that that
sounds like a dangerous nope not not if
it says AES dude animal emergency I'm
Tex a cop right now a4d yeah phone a cop
phone a cop Paw Patrol oh Paw Patrol oh
[__] I didn't even think about that
beeper beeper
but aren't you impersonating an officer
at that point is that for real felony
definitely a felony impersonating an
ambulance yeah yeah it depends on what
it says on the top okay different colen
you buzz kill you're not trying to be a
cop you're trying to be a animal
emergency service and provide a service
that does not exist for the community
the cop pulls you over you're like I'm
AES what the [__] is
this he's like is that a dog bone what
are you showing me my badge it's the
shape of a H PAW Patrol PAW Patrol Dam
that's [__] crazy man yeah there
should be one an animal emergency
service I mean there might be in like
some random like really really nice
utopian cities yeah dude this business
FR cuz you guys got to think about like
horses and [__] not just dogs it's like
oh there's a forest fire and like what
are the horse is going to do somebody
uncage the cage so the horses can run
yeah they run free dude yeah I think
people just do that the people uncage
that yeah but there's no animal
emergencies like the firemen's doing
firemen [__] you know put the horse in
the back we got to get to the
[Laughter]
hospital but like you know would it be
and I I I wouldn't want to assume too
because I'm not in law enforcement but
like let's say you pull somebody over
for like excessive speeding you know
what I mean in that situation and then
you're like put your hands out the
window or whatever and then that person
cooperates and puts your hands out the
window and then you're like get out of
the car and back up and that person gets
out of the car and back up and they're
like my dog is dying wouldn't you like
maybe just check real quick because
you're like people can that's the thing
is people lie all the time you know how
many people go my dog is dying boom boom
boom this person's never seen their
family ever again and that happens more
often than the people telling the truth
my dog is actually dying or you never go
like hey copper look over there and then
they go huh and then they run away and
they're like got me again dude this
isn't Reno
911 S fast shows up on skates you Dr SK
yeah yeah it actually happens the other
way more where there's always some
random cover oh no that's my daughter
even though it's like human trafficking
you know there's like it actually
happens the other way way more that's
why it's hard right and it's and it
sucks for the family but it's you can't
even assume that this cop is going to
even hook you up because they didn't
check until they had backup right so at
least they were covering the guy and
then they were able to to check mhm so
yeah that makes sense and the captain is
the only one that probably could like
okay excuse it cuz then now that he lies
on him and if he's willing to take the
burden then cool but if everyone else is
just like a regular Beat cop no one
wants to lose their job or get why you
let why you let this fugitive go cuz his
dog was hurt you know like oh you fell
for that you're like a [__] yeah it's so
[__] tough and at the same time
you're like [__] the family's dog is
dying though that's when you you split
the diff you police escort them to the
vet and then you arrest them then you
give them a ticket right no you put put
[__] Oscar in the back and driveing
the [__] thing you know yeah yeah
yeah you drive that's true and then you
turn on the it's not let these people go
it's like jump in my car and then the
police chief
goes and then he puts they're like why
did you put the thing on top you already
have Sirens up there he goes it's extra
important it's more
light yeah it's more
like that sucks that's a hard job yeah
dude I thought this was a comedy show
but I get it say something funny say
something funny I can't think of
anything right now dude you guys are
[__] damp in the
mood isn't it crazy though like your
mind you don't know how [__] up the
world is so you think like oh they're
going to help us and they're going to
escort us and then they probably imagine
like oh the cops are here to rescue us
and then they're going to have a big
like Convoy to the hit hospital and then
they get guns pulled on them especially
if you're a white family be like I'm
good
dude like Hey we're on the same team and
it's like shut the [__] up wait wait
wait
wait and the guy like
this what the [__] I could have swor I
was
[__] what's the point of being
white
for